¿Y cómo era ese búnker? ¿Era muy grande? ¿Pequeño?
¿Y qué comían durante ese tiempo?
Era así, mire, un piso hasta ir a la montaña. Y se mandaban siete días a la montaña.
Yo con mi hermano. Y ellos se quedaron allá.
Entonces salió.
Todos que todavía estaban escondidos
pueden ir para Dampol.
Allá van a trabajar y vamos a dejar de vivir.
Salió mi señora, con la suegra, y se fueron para Dampol.
Allá, 150.
Siete días se encaminaban hasta Wittgenstein por esa montaña.
Montaña muy grande.
Zabolsky. Javi Zabolsky.
Como yo te habla, mire, que era el más rico de Polonia, ¿no? Javi Zabolsky.
Ya estaban los mejores árboles, ya estaban tumbados.
Pero todavía era, mire, como...
Un poquito más alto. Yo tengo que ir para el baño, mi perdón.
No, no aguanto más.
Hacemos interrupción por el baño.
No aguanto más.
Seguimos con el cassette número 7 después de la interrupción.
La montaña se encaminaba, mire, no se puede caminar por el camino.
Alemanes, caballería, así, mire, por la montaña.
Comida, no hay que hablar.
Entonces me comieron secos de hierba.
¿Cómo estaba vestido usted?
¿Cómo estaba vestido?
Vestido, ¿qué tenía puesto?
Yo tenía un par de zapatos, como en Polonia lo usaban, con altos hasta acá.
¿Usted me entiende?
Con una jaquetica y camisa.
Tenía más cubecos que tela.
¿Y dónde dormían?
Así, en la sierra.
Se puso bien, pero antes se malasaban.
Llegar a Betisna, llegar a Betisna,
era, era, en, en,
no se habla aquí en mayas,
en el año 44.
43.
En el año 43.
Entonces era un puente de un kilómetro puro de piedras grandes,
de brujas.
¿Me entiende?
De brujas.
De piedras grandes.
¿Me entiende?
De brujas.
En un lado mar y en otro lado mar.
Entonces se volvieron a un puente
que está al lado de fuegos.
¿Usted me entiende?
Quemaron madera.
¿Qué pasó?
Los partisanos quemaron puentes.
Entonces aparecieron polacos
que cuidan que no quemen puentes.
Cuando llegamos al puente,
entonces mi hermano, aquí,
van a matar a nosotros.
Digo, no tengo miedo.
Vamos.
Tenemos, ya no hay más fuerza para vivir.
Ya estamos, yo estoy muriendo, voy a cruzar un chervón
corriendo sangre de mí como agua.
¿Me entiende?
Vamos, vamos a matar.
Ya está, terminado.
¿Qué pasa?
Cuando llegamos allá al puente,
dice un polaco,
cuérenos usted rápido,
ya va a llegar caballería a la mano.
Caballería, con caballos, ¿no?
Corrieron
y nos hicimos llegar en caballería.
Nosotros ya estábamos aplastados en la tierra.
¿Qué hermano era ese? ¿Cómo se llamaba?
¿Qué tal?
Cuarto hermano.
¿Qué pasó con los otros dos?
¿Sabe?
Que mataron a ellos.
Eso lo preguntó al final.
Seguimos entonces.
¿La caballería alemana?
Entonces no tenía dónde entrar
y dijo mi hermano,
vamos a donde con ese polaco
que yo escondí toda ropa y mi señora
que me guarda.
En el año 39, cuando después de mi matrimonio.
¿Te acuerdas cuando yo declaro?
Allá, tocaba la noche la ventanita.
¡Adam!
Sí.
Salió con miedo.
Abrió donde tenía caballos.
En Polonia.
Para el viernes.
Tienen paja.
Que matan para vacas, para caballos,
para comer.
Allá, nos escondieron nosotros allá.
Y la señora me curió.
Curó.
No, curó.
Con leche
y
cashe.
¿Sabes qué es cashe?
De trigo que se hace
10 días.
¿Qué tenía usted?
Chervonca.
Comer paja.
Me hizo daño al estómago
y salía sangre.
Perdón, por atrás sangre.
Como agua.
Y con esto,
ella
dice, mire señores,
también queremos vivir.
Vayan a donde tú quieras y se salvan.
Que Dios te ayude.
¿Cómo se llamaba ese polaco?
Milniczuk.
Yo dejo decir, mi señora,
cuando Dios pueda llegar,
yo voy a tocar a donde este señor.
Como llegó orden en el gueto
que cada uno
que salga
y que se vaya para
en la montaña
de Javier Zamolski,
que ya van a trabajar
y van a dejar de vivir,
mi señora fui para allá.
Ella se escapó de allá
y solo vino
como mujer,
no era tanto,
puso el pandolito como polaca
y vino de este señor.
Vino después de 10 días
que yo salió de allá
y ya no encontró.
Dice que estuvo acá,
estaba enfermo,
se me curaron
y pobrecita,
ella tenía que regresar solo allá
para Danport.
Regresar.
Ya sabía
que yo vivo.
Yo no sabía
que mi señora vino
buscarme a mí allá.
Entonces yo con mi hermano
me dijeron
no sabemos
si viven
o no viven,
vamos a arriesgarse
y vamos a buscar.
¿Cuántos pues salieron?
De este señor.
Lloró
como una niña.
Ella sacó
una ropa,
se hace para el grande,
sacó de adentro todo
no cocido
y le puso allá mantequilla
y yo a nosotros
quedó un pan
para mí y para mi hermano
y se fueron.
Se recaminaron en la noche.
Estábamos caminando
en el bosque
en la noche
oscuro.
Yo conocía ya todo el bosque,
esta era mi profesión.
Un grito
«Ruquier»,
en ruso,
«manos arriba».
Algo en el bosque
era
conocido.
En turco dijo
«Lichtenberg,
¡váyase!».
Yo conocí voz de él
y estaban partizanas
que se salvaron
y estaban
andando en montaña.
«¿De dónde vienes tú?»
Yo estoy explicando,
la verdad,
mire,
pasó así.
Salieron
todos de guetos
para Dampol
engañaron
y mataron
todos.
Allá
con estas
partizanas
era un polaco
se llamaba Váczek,
un íntimo amigo mío
que trabajaba conmigo.
Dice «mire,
tu señora
está
con vida».
«Tu señora
está
con vida
y te voy a decirte
una cosa,
que existe un dios».
Su señora
estaba con varios,
como doce personas
en un techo
donde había paja
y todos se acabaron de allá
y vieron
era un bosque,
a través del bosque
y mataron a todos.
Y tu señora
corriendo
y una gendarmería
la puso matreadora
y se trancó.
No podía matar a su señora.
«Su señora
está
de mi padre
en la casa
bajo la cama».